you
[Music]
hello everyone for the next 30 minutes
or so I'm going to be sharing with you
an use case around a be testing I'll
talk a little bit about how we started
the questions how we got to the answers
and maybe generalize a little bit how I
base can help you change the way that
you talk to your stakeholders hopefully
by the end of this talk I'll be able to
convince you that basic statistics can
actually give you the answers that you
want and also that it's not as
frightening as it might seem to be at
the beginning at least I know this is
the feedback I get sometimes a few words
about myself so I have a lot of
mathematical training in my background
but as a practicing data scientist here
are more than 15 years I you know
embarrassed admit I've been mostly doing
a practicing frequentist methods when I
was working for biotech companies or
machine learning techniques so I want to
say I'm based curious in the past few
years kept trying to kind of incorporate
Bayesian statistics back into my
workflow data scientist well so in my
honest opinion the term that the term
has been completely you know over I
would say over a hype - over a charged
with meaning by now right when you say
you a data scientist you can do so many
different things so I like to say I know
some mathematics and statistics and that
my production engineer is actually
allowing me to put some code into
production that's where I am today and
I'm kidding but of course
and currently in Shopify I'm focused on
forecasting and causality we do some
works around elasticity and optimization
and also problems that have to do with
the working inside platforms and also on
a complete tangent if you're doing NLP
we heard a really interesting talk now
for accommodations and search then
please feel free to eat me up also I'm
really interested in that and you can
find me know the usual places are
LinkedIn Twitter and github so just a
little bit about what I'm going to be
talking about today I'm gonna start with
the motivation kind of what were the
questions that we started with I'm gonna
talk about the answers that we got and
we wanted to get and we're getting now
and how we got to getting these answers
and mention some of the toolkits that we
looked at and that we're using today two
of the last points I'm not going to
touch too much on the two last points
just honor to what
there's kind of placeholders to tease
you a little bit to think more about
these kind of things one is what you do
when you can't really go can't really do
a bee testing or when a/b testing is
maybe not the right thing for you to do
and the other one a huge huge topic
coming from the world of the engineering
problem forward versus versus solution
backward if there is time I'll talk
about it if not let's talk about this
later in the office hours so let's start
I'm sorry the icons in my in my laptop
they look better so this is kind of a
simplified version so meet Nadia we love
Nadia Nadia is awesome because every
time she has a question about the
product or every time she wants to test
a new feature or want to test a new KPI
and see what it does to the product or
to the users the first thing she does of
course is to come to you her beloved
data scientist and talk to you about all
the right things about sample sizes and
about the meaning of KPIs and about the
questions that we can ask and about the
answers we can get and you know through
and what what's gonna be you know that
how what does the report gonna look like
and what it is decision downstream so
all the right things she comes to you
first thing and starts talking to you
about it even before anything goes into
any code is even written right so we
love Nadia by the way is anyone here
named Nadia okay if you know Nadia any
Nadia I'm sure she's awesome Nadia in
reality you know we don't have full
control over all the stages of the
process maybe you're working with some
platform that has some testing already
kind of hard-coded into it maybe you
don't have exactly control over the
duration or the sample size or the
questions but at least as a data
scientist you have this really healthy
check point where you can say okay given
all that we have you know given what we
have not much we want but what we
actually have we can answer question a
question B we cannot answer question C
and for some other questions well maybe
we need to run at the test differently
so at least you have this way of
controlling the conversation or giving
some kind of checkpoints and sanity
checks on what's gonna happen so it
doesn't end up when you run a test and
then you can't really get any answers
from it right so this is a pretty
realistic scenario again someplace to
start but try to do better
in some situations well you know maybe
you started your job as a product data
scientist or working for the marketing
department and you come to work and
Nadia comes to you with a ton of data
from experiments that you didn't run
that were maybe misspecified
or the KPIs were not designed correctly
or maybe there was not even a test or
maybe there was no testing done like in
a proper way and you kind of need to
start ringing out what can you do about
this base can actually help you there
I'll just mention it briefly at the end
and maybe send you some some examples
that and some code that might be
interesting for you but let's talk about
let's talk about reasonable Nadia and
when you know when you have a question
when you want to test a new feature for
example or test something else about the
product or marketing campaign or
whatever
hopefully you have all of these set up
in a satisfactory way and this would be
having a good understanding of causality
right you wanna change the feature and
you expect whatever use the happiness to
increase so we expect revenues to
increase or something to be better right
there is a KPI at the end that needs to
be impacted and we want to understand at
least the causality of what impacts what
it's an important thing to have we also
have kpi's well um we heard some talks
about today today and yesterday you know
KPI sounds sometimes really really easy
right we just count things well you know
counting things can be really really
hard you need to go to the other room to
hear how that can be sometimes when you
talk to the data engineers but let's say
we do have some understanding of that
the last three are sometimes harder than
you think even you know you might think
you are in a good place sometimes you
need to think about it a little bit
harder so volume versus velocity
you know the classic trade-off I have
you know I want to ask a question about
a really small segment of users or some
feature that's rarely being used I only
get a few clicks every month so if I
need to wait six months in order to
accumulate enough data and enough
exposure of the control and the test to
answer the question maybe in six months
this is no longer a relevant question
right so we need to think about velocity
when we design these kind of things and
also again about volume because we can
get nonsignificant results that won't be
very interesting if we don't have enough
users so it is something to think about
there's also the flip side where things
change
too quickly meaning that you know if you
think about examples like ad ads so
clicking on ads or showing ads users
sometimes you live in a really dynamic
environment and taking three months or
even two weeks to get to a decision is
too slow
by the time you kind of you know collect
the data build your model or run the
test update your assumptions two weeks
and paths and things have to change
completely
you need something faster so it is
something at least to consider is a B
testing even relevant here I'll get to
that at the end the last point when I
was writing these slides I was thinking
about the situation I've encountered
before where you start working for a
very small company they may be already
wrote some kind of a backhand they
didn't really think at the beginning
about integrating with any kind of
testing our platform or testing services
so running your tests is actually just
technical difficult that can happen
sometimes maybe you are in a better
place than I was in in some parts of my
career where you already integrated you
know that the platforms today are much
better than they used to be and they
integrate very easily with this testing
services so that's actually pretty not
as hard as it used to be I her actually
discovered a few months ago that I think
Apple just joined Google and Mozilla or
sorry Google just on Apple and Mozilla
with blocking cross-domain tracking so
basically it's gonna be harder to track
users across different domains those of
you who have been working in the
marketing space should be really really
aware of this because if you don't have
good tracking of users along the entire
journey and you only see parts of it you
know when users move between domains or
in different parts of the panel you are
gonna get a really really skewed results
so you need to be really aware of
getting the full picture and getting it
correctly but let's say with all of
these caveats we are in a place that
we're happy with and we think we can
move forward with the a/b testing so
what does Nadia want to know now they
wants to know if the new feature is
working that's that's a basic question
that's that's that's what we're here for
right we want to know if the new feature
is better than the old one we just heard
a talk is the new chatbox better than
the old one or whatever is the ad
campaign better than not doing anything
or something or whatever just a little
pet peeve of mine you know you run a
test you look at the data people start
talking
about significance or p-values or
whatever just look at the data first
sometimes you need just you pass what I
like to what I love this acronym you
know the intra ocular trauma test
meaning that he just hits you between
the eyes right so if you're there you're
lucky but I really encourage you just
you know first thing just to get the
data sometimes you can just see things
there I remember working for a biotech
company working with some researchers
doctors medical doctors and we had a lot
of discussions again because we wanted
to publish the results in journal in a
good journal and the doctors told us at
some point you know we can wait with the
you know with the P values in the sample
size and everything which I can see the
results with my eyes if I need
statistics to prove that something's
working we're already in trouble right
but life is noisy and complicated and
sometimes you want to measure something
a really small effect in a really noisy
environment and this is why you know we
run the test and we run the test we
collect the data and then we go on it
meet Nadia you know to conclude the
whole thing another once you know okay
is it working is the new feature better
is the companion' working whatever and
here starts this little strange song and
dance that we as data scientist often do
because let's be honest we can't really
answer that question directly when we do
a/b testing what we can say is the
following we saw an increase of 5% in
this KPI or in this conversion rate or
whatever with a p-value of 0.05 percent
okay um this is great right this is
really interesting but this is not the
answer to Nadia's question the problem
is Nadia thinks that you answer the
question when people hear this is
statistically significant people think
okay this is working and this is
absolutely not the case so oh um and
promised the only math equations you're
going to see today promise what is P
value so I can read this you p value
okay it's a probability of seeing the
data conditional on the null hypothesis
that is not working what does it mean in
a human language it means imagine a
parallel universe a galaxy far far away
where there is no effects where the new
feature is not working this
not a hypothesis this is not an idea
this is the absolute concise reality of
things we're talking philosophy here you
understand this is the absolute reality
of things and in this parallel universe
we run an experiment there is no effect
we shouldn't see anything and we see the
data that we see and we are surprised
that is P value that is what p value
quantifies p value quantifies surprise
in a universe when there is no effect
when there is no change and this is not
the same as answering the question is it
working it's not the same thing this is
what Nadya actually wants to know Nadya
wants to know it's called the posterior
distribution or again probability that
something is working or where is the KPI
where we think the KPI is now having
seen the data it's called a posterior
distribution this is actually the answer
Nadia wants Nadia needs and in order to
calculate this quantity we need three to
calculate three different things one is
the likelihood which comes from the
model in the case of a B testing it's a
very very simple thing the second thing
the probability of the data which is
something a little bit harder to
calculate luckily the tools that we have
today are much better rated and one of
the reasons based on statistics kind of
lagged behind machine learning and
frequentist approaches is because this
historically was really hard to
calculate it's not the case now it's
getting much better and the third one is
the prior we'll get to the prior before
that I just wanted to mention so why
what led me to think about Bayesian
statistics because first of all I just
wanted to answer the damn question I
wanted to be able to answer the question
is something working yes or no or it is
what's the probability that it's working
again p-values I started realizing
they're actually well not just me there
are a source of miscommunication there
is a really cool article that someone
wrote with really nice examples on huge
effects with really high p-values no
effect with really low p-values you can
get all of this real weird mixture
together in though these examples and
there is a name if you want a title it's
called the replication crisis that hit
social science and biology pretty hard I
started reading papers about people from
growth teams in companies that kind of
you know these teams that come in and
try to do a lot of testing and
optimization of products or
funnels and they are complaining now
that okay I ran a lot of tests I got I
chose the feature I thought were best
and when I put it in productions I don't
see the results I expected so I think it
just creates a lot of miscommunication
Bayesian statistics is also a good way
of thinking about problems I'll touch
that briefly and you also have really
good tools that I think putting place
really good processes so I mentioned the
three quantities I promised I'll talk
about the prior because prior is maybe
the most tricky maybe the most
controversial part of this process
quoting from Wikipedia and this is my
comment in the middle the prior
distribution the probability
distribution that would express one's
beliefs that's my comment yes this is a
belief about the quantity before some
evidence since taking into account so
imagine the situation you have your
models let's say a really good model
conversion model for the US and you want
to run an experiment or want to test
something in France and you have no
information a prior distribution is me
coming to you before seeing any
information from let's say France or
Spain and asking you where do you think
the conversion rate is so this is where
anywhere talks yesterday about expert
opinion about integrating subject matter
expert into your team in a good way this
is where Bayesian statistics can of
forces you to do it in a way the process
is built-in because you have to go and
ask people what you think is going on
before seeing anything it's part of the
process that you have to do but luckily
again distributions are flexible things
applicable this thing and if for example
I think it's probably around 50% but I'm
not sure then look at the orange line
right centered at 50 percent but gives a
lot of probability mass to other values
as well maybe I think it's either 0 or 1
but probably not in the middle then look
on the red line most of the probability
sits at either 0 or 1 it's called a
horseshoe prior also and I don't think
there's anything happening in not not in
the middle like people are the go hero
there maybe it did another thing maybe I
think it's you know my expert told me we
think it's around 20% but we're not sure
so I maybe I'll use that purple line
over there to quantify my belief before
doing anything so we need to do that and
again choosing a prior I said this is
subjective but there are really good
guidelines
sometimes you have these natural
Reince some kpi's are only positive so
you need to choose a positive
distribution sometimes you know a be
testing if you want to be really
conservative then you can say okay the
distribution is centered around zero and
you just need to kind of decide how
uncertain you are you can do a lot of
really cool exercises that engage your
stakeholders in a really meaningful
conversation about what we expect to see
what we think the effect would be versus
where we see it after we look at the
data and run the experiment again really
really healthy discussions to have with
stakeholders around where we think you
are when we think we're going and also
explains to you as a data scientist what
people think what are the expectations
you can discover really interesting
things sometimes and also for the
stakeholders to kind of get a better
picture of what you're doing and you can
do cool things like gamification and
other things you know would that you
usually do with training sets
if you lucky you have some guide as some
benchmarks sometimes and sometimes your
tool just restrict you some some very
simple choices and then you just need to
be smart about making these simple
choices sometimes you can just choose
some Gaussian form and then you just
need to choose which one to go that make
kind of make sense beyond that you can
go pretty crazy with Bayesian models you
can build really complicated ones and
then choosing priors becomes really
difficult think about just what is the
prior over correlation matrix of some
different phenomenons that you're
looking at that becomes really tricky
but there are really good guidelines
there's a link to a paper by McHale
Betancourt one of the main contributors
to Stan that wrote a really really good
paper about this recommended reading but
think about it this way you just got a
new a new job description you translate
business insights into distributions and
this can be this is the new role for use
the data scientists so let's say we got
some opinions some prior opinions is
about where we think the effect should
be again a be testing is pretty simple
it's zero but we can quantify how
uncertain we are what the effect is
going to be and we run you know we run
the we run the we collect the data we
calculate the posterior distribution and
then we go again to sit down with Nadia
and she asks again okay I listened to
you talk for hours about Bayesian
statistics and you convinced me that
this is good we may be you know we let
you build your models and everything can
you please tell me if you know if the
new feature is working
and the answer is yes so if you look at
the posterior distribution there we
looked at the data and given everything
that we kind of know and everything that
we collected we now think that if I had
to give a number like a single single
number I would probably say that effect
Li is some what I'm measuring in is
around two right this is kind of the
peak of the distribution when you have
these nice new peaks but we can do much
more because we can start talking about
certainty and uncertainty we can start
saying okay 95% probability that this is
between 0 and 5 it's called high density
interval
there's also EDI I forgot what the e
stands for but it means that you kind of
chop two equal tails from both sides
sometimes they're the same sometimes not
so we can say okay this is what we think
it is and this is where we are 95%
certain that it is this is not the same
as confidence interval that's not what
confidence interval stands for please
again if you know if it is not clear I
hope it's clear now convinced interval
again talks about this alternate reality
and here we say in this reality we think
having seen the data that this is where
the KPI is now living but we can answer
more questions for example you know we
talked about again running a test seeing
positive results putting something in
production
maybe you're not really certain about
these positive results what is the risk
we're taking here right what's the
probability we're actually we're
actually going to do damage we can
answer that because we can look at the
probability of being below zero okay of
the difference being actually negative
and say look everything looks great
there is a 20% chance we're actually
doing damage are you willing to take
that chance again a different
conversation to have with your
stakeholders as data scientists not just
what we see but also talking about risks
as well same it's called Type S type
sign error same thing for magnitude we
see two what's the probability that is
20 or 200 or kind of completely off the
scale we can say how should we are about
that a really really good thing that
happened you know especially when you
talk about features sometimes there's
some kind of a budget involved in the
conversation that you need to take into
account so sometimes another will tell
you anything below 3% does not justify
the changes we need to do in production
in order to deploy this why
is the risk we're taking here in terms
of not returning the investment so you
know to zero it's basically any
threshold that you want to set you can
say what's a probability being above or
below the threshold and then your
stakeholders can take really data-driven
decisions right this is a really really
cool feature here I'm not going to go
into base factors there is some argument
about them because they kind of try to
go around the prior but maybe for a
different talk so hopefully I've
convinced you that this is a really
great set of answers and really great
set of questions to ask and answers to
get how do we get them well there are a
lot of tools out there again trying to
put it on a graph
there are what I call the low level
frameworks
I think perhaps my favorite and maybe
one of the most prominent in the past
years is Stan it's it's not written it's
kind of language agnostic is it has
bindings to Python and to R and to other
languages as well you need to learn a
new language in a sense and a new way of
working with with a you know a new
programming language and some new tools
and new ideas but you can it's portable
it's clock it's cross-platform and it's
super powerful and super flexible you
can really start with a clean slate you
don't have to have any assumption you
can start with a clean slate and kind of
build your model a really complicated
model again a be testing maybe a little
bit of an overkill you can use some
nicer packages but if you want to go
further I highly recommend that you at
least look into those into Stan times t3
is a pure Python package and there are
other ones I guess all the ones bugs and
jugs and all these kind of things that
have usually bindings to R and Python
and other languages somewhere in the
middle there are these frameworks
I like BSP I've used it a lot for other
use cases where you can do a/b testing
it's framework that are actually really
flexible and really powerful but usually
designed to solve a specific problem
bsts is designed to solve time series
issues and causality but they give a lot
of flexibility but there is a trade-off
there you can only choose some
distribution some structures they have
some assumptions behind them and kind of
last but definitely not least are all
the nice free candy that you can get
thanks to thanks to the wonderful
open-source community people right you
know a lot of wrappers around these
frameworks
one of the famous one profit which made
a lot of noise from Facebook it's a
wrapper around Stan that does
timeseriesforecasting it's focused
around trends not around a more round
trends less around causality so great to
use as long as you understand what
you're wrapping around right did you
understand the model VRMs Stan AR M may
be more useful if you go for a be
testing you can actually run the ABT you
can actually calculate things in those
packages and they give you the nice are
syntax that you use from a linear
regression
BFBS is actually what's powering
Google's causal impact for those of you
who heard about it so that's what
powering that again it's a wrap around
it really nice like one-liner that can
do really complicated things and there's
a whole universe of our packages I just
wanted to mention to be ESD and bases
are which are kind of really simple
focused on on a be testing and these
kind of simple questions and can
sometimes help you guide you through the
process if you you new to the new to
this just a few mentions of things
beyond a be testing I promise I'm I'll
just say a few words about this every
testing is wonderful it's you know the
best way to answer questions except when
it's not so when isn't when it when
isn't it a good way to to answer
questions when you're outside this
what's called in physics the Goldilocks
zone you know not too hot not too cold
not too bright not too dark there's a
really narrow band where life can exist
so too fast too slow so where things are
too slow again when it takes six months
to gather enough information to answer a
question maybe a B testing is not the
right thing to do and again with
Bayesian statistics you can inject more
information through the Pires kind of
say I'm pretty sure this is what's
happening and let's slow trickle of data
kind of update your beliefs as you go so
it is you can start from somewhere so it
helps that also you can run a lot of a B
test a long time like these disjointed
tests and completely miss the fact that
there is an underlying for not
phenomenon because it's just happening
really slowly there is a change in the
market new competition you haven't heard
of just changing your customer base
or whatever something's changing
underground and when you kind of you're
able to combine these tests into a
single test into a single model you can
actually inject the effect of time into
your model throughout the different AP
tests this is kind of this idea of
pulling or hierarchical models there's
one at a time train in the background
that kind of affects your test a long
time and you can actually incorporate
that into your models and catch this
okay where you if you just run a a
disjointed set of AP tests you can stay
pretty blind same thing for too fast
sometimes you need to make a really fast
decision so which ad to show to which
customer if you need to update your
model every week or every two weeks
maybe that's too slow there's a whole
universe of tools around that with the
evasion for those who heard of
multi-armed bandit that's I think kind
of that almost in DC standard today it's
a Bayesian method that basically helps
you make decision really really fast
when you can't just don't want to do the
cycle of you know collect data stop
update the model stop deploy new
decision model stop collect new data
stop you need to do things in real time
and the same thing I mentioned before
you know this some pooling idea if you
only have a really small segment that
you're interested in you you don't have
enough information kind of to make a lot
of influence throughout them but you do
want to try and see something are they
different how different are they
bayesian tools are really really great
for that because you can do something
called pooling insurance companies for
example I worked a lot with in nature in
space so you know you have your
portfolio and you want to calculate the
risk in order to calculate your premium
right what's our risky you are the
customer and sometimes you only have one
Maserati in your portfolio so how do you
calculate the risk for you know N equals
one there are actually interesting way
of doing that and again I encourage you
to investigate that other cases where
okay
you can't just can't test it's just not
possible technically legally from a
regulatory perspective and what you do
then how do you say something is working
especially when there's a lot of noise
again really really cool concepts from
our base in statistics this is an
example I present in London two weeks
ago with a causal impact from Google and
how we kind of try to see okay we have
to release the public campaign how can
you prove that the campaign had any
effect on anything that is not just
noise and seasonality these model help
you to break
down this into really really in try to
break down what you see the noise that
you see in two different components and
try to estimate that the way that I do
it by the way is trying to simulate the
control group it's really really
interesting approach but if you want
come and talk to me about this later
I'll be happy to talk about it and
there's also a link here to a github
repository with the YouTube video and
some code examples so feel free to to
look into that one last thing again I'm
not going to touch on it because of time
I I just you know want to say one of the
reasons I'm really excited about going
kind of going back I would say to
Beijing statistics when you use
frequencies tools and when use machine
learning tools it's a very tool oriented
approach it's kind of okay what can I
solve with neural networks what can i
solve with GBM what can I saw okay so
it's it's you kind of start with the
tool a lot of the time neural networks
are flexible but you know can be there
is an interesting trade-off there
especially in terms of explained ability
and we heard yesterday to talk about
okay the more complex the model then
usually the less you understand
different behaviors and different
problems that come up from it and if you
talk about frequent these tools okay I
have this really complicated
multivariate phenomenon that's changing
over time and I want an insane causality
so I usually try to squeeze it into some
you know some model that I know
ARIMA re/max or maybe some regression
model or something else they're usually
a lot of squeezing that needs to happen
and a lot of things that you need to
chop off along the way just because you
have a package it kind of does what you
want but not exactly and you need to
decide okay maybe this package and you
you try it a lot and then you reach a
dead end in any try another package it
has a completely different set up and
different trade-offs not a very I would
say another very flexible a set of tools
and basing tools actually I almost want
to say too flexible it's really easy
when you work with this low-level
framework to specify super super
complicated models and then the
trade-off becomes x to solve again I've
seen these amazing work so people are
doing for example trying to understand
gas flow in pipes in order to to predict
problems in infrastructure and they
actually start from you know
thermodynamic equations and build the
model up from there like these amazing
scientific works or people
it for very practical reasons or for
scientifically in the scientific domain
you know people looking at equations of
gravity and building a model of the
distribution of galaxies you can really
go really far out the problem then
becomes time to estimate the posterior
distribution it becomes computationally
heavy but I really like the fact that
kind of you have more room to maneuver
more room to think about your problems
as the way that you think they are not
how the tool tells you to think about
them and I really like it for me it kind
of brings back a little bit of the
science back in to data science which is
something I'm really passionate about so
again there is a trade-off there the
complexity and everything but at least
you have the flexibility and the ability
to choose how complex you want to go and
I'll again just mention what I mentioned
before the paper by Michael Betancourt
which is a really really good guideline
and way of thinking about complexity as
well not just about priors
in conclusion hopefully I've convinced
you that p-value is a really wonderful
answer but to the completely to the
wrong question to do a completely wrong
question based on models again can give
you the answer that you need and the
answer that you want to give if you're
willing to have an opinion the prior and
you're willing to change it both of them
maybe not as hard as you not as easy as
you might think
so also again basing tools are a really
good way to start if you're willing to
put in the investment to start going
into this domain of having better
discussions and better questions and
better understanding with your
stakeholders about the problem and
better understanding of your
stakeholders about the answers that
you're giving them so it's a really good
way of opening better communication
channels for use the data scientists and
for your teams that you're working in
and kind of finally a little bit about
at the warning before you go out there
and start you know doing Bayesian
statistics especially if you're using
the wrappers and the packages just be
aware of what's standing behind them so
the packages look really nice it's
almost too easy to run these hyper
complicated models just be worth the
assumptions behind them if you want I
can tell you really good stories about
profit versus bsts there's other things
and how you know it seems things are not
always as they are so you need to be
aware of what's happening also
underneath the surface not just run the
command and look at the results be aware
of the of the underlying models as I
said a lot of that has to do with these
underlying models of real
see that you at least need to be aware
of and understand before you go ahead
but with that said I really encourage
you to try these things when you go back
to work tomorrow on or on Monday and
think about your next test that you're
going around or the next question you're
going to ask or the next model that
you're going to build consider going
based this time so this would be a good
time for questions thank you thanks for
your very nice and instructive talk as
you know in the business of I'm also in
a internet startup typically a B tests
are not judged by one single metric but
several and my question was so there's a
pretty well-established framework that I
know to deal with multiple multiple
hypothesis testing in the frequency
domain is there an equivalent in the
Bayesian framework that you describe so
it really depends on so answer is pretty
much yes if you look at multiple KPIs
what you need to say is okay I need to
have a better prior in a sense so you
need to say not just why I expect for
example the conversion rate to live and
the revenues to live after the test I
also need to say something about the
correlation between them which is maybe
not as hard as you think not not so easy
but as maybe not so hard and maybe and
again it goes back to what I mentioned
about this disciplined workflow where
you can start by saying I can start
running just without any correlation
between them see what comes out and then
make the model more complicated as we go
when you talk about the frequentist
situation you have this problem of
multiple comparisons right which you can
abuse your model when you do Bayesian
statistics but at least multiple
comparisons are not not not not exactly
a problem in that domain so you can try
different things and see how complicate
the model as much as you like but I
think the answer to your question is yes
you just need to understand how come
with an opinion about what's the
correlation between your different KPIs
and by the way they are again there are
tools and frameworks that we have to do
you